well as those discussions continue on
Capitol Hill one of reddit's co-founders
is revealing how he plans to contribute
in this fight against racism Alexis
Ohanian is a father of two year-old
daughter with his wife that Serena
Williams he resigned from Redditt Board
of Directors on Friday and he urged the
board to replace him with a black
candidate he also promised to donate
future gains on his reddit stock to
initiatives that support the black
community in an exclusive interview he
told us how he made the decision for his
lovely daughter
I didn't arrive at this easily it was it
was absolutely a hard decision but
thinking back especially on the position
our country's been in and then
especially in the last few weeks I
realized I needed to look at myself look
in the mirror and see what I could do to
help contribute some real positive
change so that I could look my daughter
in the eye when she's a little bit older
and she asks me what I did to help make
this country in this world a little bit
better for her and for for a whole lot
of people who look like her tech
entrepreneur Alexis Ohanian co-founded
the popular social sharing website
reddit back in 2005 he has served as
executive chairman since 2015 o hanyan
is married to tennis superstar Serena
Williams
they are parents to an adorable
two-year-old daughter Olivia fatherhood
played a big role in his decision to
resign from reddit's Board and his
request to be replaced by a black
candidate I'm struck you just said it
was a hard decision what was the hardest
thing about it for you
you know reddit was my first child I
started it right on a college I was a
kid who walked out of an LSAT to go to a
Waffle House and decided he wanted to
become an entrepreneur but looking
inward it was a hard decision until it
was a really easy one when I remember
that my greatest creation is not and
never will be reddit it's my daughter
and I want her to be proud of her father
well you've certainly done that and I
will say listen you had your your skill
set is vast including braiding your
daughter's hair every time I see that
picture it just makes me smile that's
growth and I and I think whether it's
learning how to braid my daughter's
beautiful hair or whether it is it is
growing to accept my own blind spots
that growth mindset is so important
yesterday
reddit got the message and added tech
CEO Michael Seibel to the board but
couldn't you have if you'd wanted to
just said we're going to add a black
person to the board did you have to step
down I think there is something symbolic
about someone in my position stepping
aside as a way to say we're not just
going to make sure that that you have a
seat at the table I'm gonna give up my
seat so that you can have it I do
believe in in what that represents and I
hope it makes boardrooms all across the
country look around the table and say
who are we serving who is our community
Ohanian says more diversity is in the
best interests of Reddit in the tech
industry more broadly reddit has faced
criticism because hate speech has not
been moderated in the message boards on
the platform but Ohanian venture capital
company initialised has been investing
in new startups that will target hate
online I think if we follow this
drumbeat of support both offline and
online I think we're gonna see more and
more tech businesses in particular
taking more responsibility over not just
the content on their platforms but also
the diversity of their workforces as you
know there are very few black faces in
the boardroom so you thought about that
too and your own experience Alexis in a
boardroom yeah there's this striking
double standard because I have never
walked in a room and not felt a hundred
percent confident be there not felt a
hundred percent welcomed there at times
when I really shouldn't have been
because of my inexperience or because of
my youth or because of my whatever but
that is the privilege that I have locked
my entire life there are things that I
do that my wife checks me on that I'm
doing with the best of intentions but
still require me to feel that pain and
then dig deeper and I'm wondering what
does she helped you see that you didn't
see before there are situations where I
default
fact to be heard because all of my life
when I bring something up I'm generally
in a position where someone is going to
hear me take my side and trust what I
have to say and I take that for granted
and it's not until I am you know talking
to my wife about things that I really
understand that that is not a luxury she
has had do you think that you would have
come away around to this way of thinking
if you had not been with Serena in
particular hmm I would love to say yes
but to see look to have that front-row
seat to her not just her greatness but
everything she has to endure much of it
that never gets reported on that no one
sees right that made the education come
really quickly especially when this is
someone you love but Alexis is you know
nobody likes to be called out people get
very defensive yeah that seems to be
changing but I think it is it is
changing that discomfort that we feel
physically when we push ourselves to go
further is something that we usually
embrace right we know that that's where
growth happens that's where muscles are
tearing just a little bit so they regrow
stronger these conversations are that
same kind of exercise they're that same
kind of discomfort for our brains and
for our souls because at the end of the
day if what we're asking is privileged
white people to be able to feel a little
bit of discomfort to have a hard
conversation that's it's a very
reasonable ask yeah Alexis Ohanian is
saying Lena and white people lead in
enjoyed the discomfort I really
appreciated his candor and he's walking
the walk and talking to talk the first
million in his and his profits in his in
his the first million will go to Colin
Kaepernick's know your rights
so he's pledging his future reddit gains
and the first million because he
believes that Colin Kaepernick is
someone who has transcended his sports
and will show that he's on the right
side of history
so Tony I really enjoyed talking to him
I really appreciated the candor that he
said that he had if you notice on the
wall in the room
did the interview it said pain is gross
pain is girls he believes that I did
notice that I did notice that he's
really comfortable with being
uncomfortable and wants others to be as
well the symbolism is so big right now
it is not going to be enough to have the
best of intentions it's not going to be
enough to follow the golden rule and
treat everyone the same if we are going
to fix the problem of inequality it's
gonna have to take intention and action
Anthony and I think Alexis is really
putting it on the line for the rest of
us to say look it's gonna be sacrifices
well yeah I mean I think his point about
stepping down as a way of showing we're
not just willing to give a seat on the
board to a black person we're willing to
give up our seat to allow a black person
in very symbolic it doesn't sound like a
big difference but it's actually a huge
difference I think Gail oh you're so
right Anthony it's huge and the reaction
from the tech world in the business
community says has been very positive
he's gotten a lot of calls from people
saying how did you do what to do that
they want to engage so I think it's very
important he's sending quite a strong
message thank you very much Alexis
Ohanian